my name is Willie I'm working as a
charity card but at the same time I'm
selling a time you know
I love no one because they change my
life induct incest Watty no money in
emails anytime much of Africa the really
essential services that are being
provided using prepaid payment
mechanisms like the mobile telephony
electricity and even water were provided
not by the state but by a formal
entrepreneurs the poor you were and
farther you were from business centers
the more expensive it was for you to
access these services and that really
resonates with no man anywhere you can
make those payments available and
affordable everywhere we've developed a
point-of-sale terminal and the product
is delivered wirelessly at the time when
people need it people rely on us to earn
an income and posting our application on
Google cloud platform gives us a much
higher reliability then we could have
got posting in ourselves month of the
month we've had 100% uptime on our
production application and I know that
we would have been able to do that on
our own my customers know me very well
in his column you take mr. time we
started off with one release a month in
2011 to six to ten releases a day and
that's been a huge advantage for us
Google cloud platform helps with that
because it makes releasing code simple
we respect the end user a lot and we
look very closely at the merchants needs
we've managed to turn around the product
take feedback from the market and solve
a brand new business need and need our
consumers have I helped a lot of people
I've caught everything what I need
because of no money
you